in this 1989 revlon commercial the
cosmetics company asked a question to
its customers
what makes a woman unforgettable a
little luck
in the right shade of red the answer to
that question was of course
revlon cosmetics for much of the 20th
century revlon products were a mainstay
in the makeup aisle
once capturing a fifth of all department
store cosmetic sales in the united
states
but in the 21st century revlon has found
itself battling declining market share
and increasingly crowded shelf space
now with the company recently averting a
bankruptcy filing
questions remain if the once
unforgettable brand is on its way to
being forgotten
you know when you look wonderful you
feel wonderful
and the secret can be the makeup you use
revlon helped usher in the era of color
cosmetics in the first half of the 20th
century
the company was founded in 1932 by
charles revson
along with his brother joseph and
chemist charles lachman
it started by selling nail polish but
quickly moved into lipsticks
sales of cosmetics surged between 1941
and 1946. revlon positioned itself to
meet this demand
claiming its products were seen on the
fingertips and lips of the nation's
smartest women
revlon is a brand that for for for
decades really for a generation was
the biggest most ubiqui ubiquitous
um sought-after kind of cutting edge
brands and it was what you thought of
when you thought of
mass-market uh yet very desirable makeup
the cornerstones of revlon's rise were
mass production
and mass marketing it spent heavily on
advertising
sponsoring popular tv programs and
penning exclusive deals with beauty shop
suppliers
charles refson is said to have described
revlon's strategy like this in the
factory we make cosmetics
in the store we sell hope selling hope
helped bolster the company's sales
and in the 1960s and 70s revlon branched
out
expanding into pharmaceuticals and
apparel
in 1975 charles revson died and european
businessman michele bergerac took the
helm
a year later revlon sales reached nearly
1 billion
although it was still second in sales
behind avon products with this
door-to-door distribution
the cosmetics conglomerate kept pace
with changing trends as more women
entered the workforce
marketing its products to on-the-go
career-driven women
now the world belongs to charlie by
revlon
but by the early 1980s sales had
flattened
and in a decade marked by hostile
takeovers one of the top corporate
raiders had revlon in his sights
businessman ron perlman initiated a
hostile takeover of revlon in 1985.
the takeover bid dominated headlines
detailing the struggle between pearlman
and bergerac for control of the company
he said to me very proudly that
he hunted lions and tigers so
i was not a threat to him ultimately
pearlman prevailed
becoming chairman of revlon's board and
controlling shareholder
pearlman enlisted famed fashion
photographer richard avedon to shoot the
unforgettable ad campaign bringing top
supermodels like christy turlington
and cindy crawford to be the faces of
revlon at first blush
revlon appeared poised to end the
century on a high note
however its finances were telling a
different story
perlman had used junk bonds to finance
the takeover
it was assumed he would sell revlon's
non-beauty businesses to pay down this
debt
instead he turned his focus to a failed
bid to take over gillette
and this came at a time when competition
was heating up
procter gamble acquired several makeup
brands snatching up a third of the
cosmetics market by 1990 compared to
revlon's share of just over 20 percent
at the same time revlon was stretched
thin it was carrying nine upscale
product lines with nearly 3 000
individual products
but women were wearing less and less
makeup as they moved away from the
bright colors of the 80s to more muted
natural looks the company launched its
hit colorstay non-transferable lipstick
in 1995
and went public in 1996. however much of
revlon's pre-tax profits were going to
service its 1.3 billion dollars of debt
late in the century it turned into a
company that was just a little bit
behind the trends
um you know things started fashion
started shifting away from these bright
colors
and revlon didn't adapt to that change
uh it didn't it you know it caught on
somewhat late to the shift toward
skin care and skin health and was still
really
selling kind of these um you know these
color cosmetics that were
changing by 2003 revlon had experienced
16 straight quarters of losses
and by 2007 its share of the cosmetics
market had fallen to
11 in mass-market retailers
despite this perlman continued to keep
the company afloat
with injections of cash in a revolving
door of ceos
mr perlman he said uh even this was more
than a decade ago in an interview
with the wall street journal he said you
know for good or bad i'm defined by
revlon
he led rescues he just bailed the
company out over and over again as it
continued to struggle
revlon tried to recapture part of the
market with high profile acquisitions of
calmer group in elizabeth arden
but by 2017 its market share had
dwindled to around six percent
by then revlon was not only facing stiff
competition from the likes of procter
and gamble and l'oreal
but from startups with serious star
power
celebrity-backed makeup lines like kylie
jenner's kylie cosmetics
had burst onto the scene you know
company whether it's revlon whether it's
covergirl these are companies that have
massive advertising budgets models
tv commercials and you know with the
with the rise of social media we're
seeing brands that are driven by
you know we influencers by you know
kylie jenn jenner who has
um you know a cosmetics company that has
200 million
dollars in annual sales even though you
know there's only less than a dozen
people who work at her company
and she doesn't spend money on
advertising because she just has so many
instagram followers
in 2018 perlman provided revlon with a
financial lifeline
and installed his daughter deborah as
ceo the company's first
female chief executive through much of
2020
widespread closures and bankruptcies
among retailers salons and spas
crimp sales of beauty products the main
thing is that
our lips are covered when we wear masks
so lipstick sales have
have fallen off there used to be a term
in the industry called the lipstick and
index and how much women were spending
on makeup kind of as a proxy for the
economy and he said we can't really use
the lipstick index anymore because
nobody can see our lips the dip couldn't
have come
at a worse time for revlon with a 343
million dollar bond payment loaming
revlon refinanced its debt to avoid
bankruptcy
if you look at kind of some of the
analysts and some of the industry
experts they question whether this
deal to safe revlon has just kicked the
can down the road
um certainly old brands brands that are
struggling have
revived themselves before i would say
revlon has a tougher road and it's an
entire company not
a brand but it's hard you know it's hard
to say where they're going to end up
where revlon ends up will depend on how
it adapts to the modern beauty landscape
and if it can inject a little color into
an otherwise bleak outlook